with me it was tough to get to and one
easy road to get today my feeling i've
been doubted my whole career not just no
fellow college when i told my two ACLs a
lot of people say no i won't even be
here two or three years and now no my
you're 15 still having the phones to
make a play you still help it you know a
team win games and bless Frank Gore
after Sunday's win by the Buffalo Bills
over the Denver Broncos more importantly
for Gore he is now number three all-time
on the career rushing list something
that is not supposed to happen in this
era of fantasy football passing numbers
and revolving door tailback position
it's amazing what he has done and that
leads us into it's all it is he's a Hall
of Famer I saw an article is he in the
class those guys right there for me
absolutely not absolutely not in what
way it just he's just not he's not a
Hall of Fame I'm saying he is a Hall of
Famer but he's not in the class of those
guys that are on that graph what do you
mean by the class because me to me
though don't differ than Emmitt Smith I
disagree with you there
Emmitt Smith is a guy who was able to
show up every week right he ran hard yep
he hit the holes yeah had a great team
around him sure wasn't the fastest guy
he wasn't the shipyard that's Frank Gore
he's Frank Gore who didn't get to play
on a great I don't think you know I
still think if you went back and we took
the hundred greatest runs from Emmitt
Smith's career the hundred greatest runs
at Frank Gore you'd go whoa Emmitt
Smith's were definitely better it's not
even close he's breaks tackles but I
mean again I'm not trying to like take
anything away from Frank Gore but I also
don't think he's in the super elite
class of some of the people he's passing
up I don't I just thought he's still
passing them up he is that's nice an
amazing amazing think that makes it even
more impressive that he's getting more
career yardage than guys who were
physically superior to him yeah it is
that's what's amazing exactly right
that's really it's almost the test of
time it's the test of will because he
had three ACL injuries when he was at
Miami and just all of those things
that's where it's phenomenal but again I
would argue I'm not sure through his
great career I think there's
one year where you'd say he was one of
the five best running backs in football
that's the only thing I fight he had a
season 1600 plus four he did and that
would probably be the year I would look
at it you know so that that's where I
good I know I'm not trying to sound like
a hater it's apparent knock the Hall of
Famers it's right there go ahead you
lead it off since I just led that charge
well I want I mean I want to give I want
to give some love to Frank Gore okay
good let's continue the conversation
then I'd say I mean the Frank this is
the Frank Gore is all a Famer award I
there was an article I don't know who
wrote it right the name didn't ring a
bell somebody in the Washington Post
said he's in all aha oh not all of Famer
are you kidding me the guy's not a
hall-of-famer look the guys had the
longevity he's had the durability it is
the toughest position to play yeah all
the time about the car crash right to be
able to come back year after year to
earn a spot on a roster to earn playing
time to earn the reps to earn the trust
of a coaching staff right to be the guy
who runs into the brick wall play after
play week after week year after year and
you look back at his career it is
incredible what he's done it is and and
I I talked to him yesterday
yeah and I said look I've been in this
you're a hall-of-famer camp for several
years what do you say when you hear
people say you're not and he started
rattling off numbers but years when the
49ers had no offensive line and they
were signing guys off the street and he
still averaged four yards of carry over
and over and over again this is a guy
who just keeps going and going and going
and going a guy who shouldn't have
played for very long it's amazing to see
it happen because so few can pull that
off and to play as long as he has to get
to where he is to pass Barry freakin
Sanders yeah we know Sanders would have
had more than anybody if he would have
played as long as he could have but
still to pass a guy like Barry Sanders
and to have a reasonable shot at Walter
Payton night Walter Payton's 1,500 yards
yeah I said what about painting so we'll
see and as long as they keep giving them
opportunities I think that's what's more
impressive than anything else yeah he
wants to keep doing it yeah he's in
shape to keep doing it but he still
finds teams that let him have the role
where he can keep racking definitely
that sort it is it's will its toughness
of course there's talent I'm not trying
to take anything away from him there you
know the games do you think he's missed
due to injury during his career
yeah I mean I almost want to just say
four or five it's ten yeah still seems
like not
that's insane we're running back again I
would argue that it's it's worse to be
I'm running back in the NFL than it is
to be a heavyweight boxer yeah I mean
that's how much you get smashed I mean I
used to skip the ball the running backs
whether it be Mike Alstott or Cadillac
Williams and I'd be like oh my gosh
my neck would have broke seven times on
that play like how could they do that
because you ever like flinch from the
sound of the collisions without a doubt
I used to literally turn I used to get
yelled at by Gruden's sometimes cuz he'd
be like would you carry out your fakes
and that was like I had to turn around
and watch that run not just you know
because I would be an amazing you'd hear
crap oh my gosh II stole what he's still
running what so that's that's amazing um
I think I'm gonna go to still fightin
Award for the fight in New York Jets
alright just I'm just amazed by what
they're doing here as of late you know
again it wasn't very easy to pack it in
Adam GaSe everybody wants his head a few
weeks ago we got to fire him
what's going on with Sam Donald he
doesn't look good and here we are the
New York Jets just absolutely put a
beat-down on the Oakland Raiders
yesterday who are in the AFC playoff
conversation now the score is misleading
I do want to say that the Raiders had
some really big drops in the first half
of that game that would have changed the
outlook and the forecasts of the game to
where I think it's closer but regardless
Adam GaSe has done a phenomenal job of
starting games out you know we talked
about coaches with their first 10 or
their first 12 you know the Jets have
been a machine the last few weeks in the
first drive of the game and that's all
coaching and figuring out the right
plays and sequencing to go down and have
those scores Sam Donald has played
really well now this play right here if
you're watching on TV there was a
roughing the passer call on the first
dryer e questionable I mean pitiful
pitiful hey that's all I can say but
that gave the Jets up first down gives
them first and goal Sam Donald runs it
in the next play but Darnell's played
good not only within the pocket but as
we've seen when it becomes backyard
football he's really good
Robbie Anderson's getting going
everything about the Jets it's been very
impressive and and again here's another
great play design Sam Donald looking to
the right gonna throw it looks like a
screen pass kind of pumps it and they
got a little
braxton Barrios over the middle he makes
a big play
so it's creative game plan good play all
together the Jets defense their run
defense was phenomenal yesterday against
that big big offensive line with the
Raiders and the Jets just they got a
little momentum here and something to
build on and you know it's like Le'Veon
Bell said trust the process a little bit
he's been around the block a few times
and I think he saw some positive things
from the coaching staff and the
organization that he liked let's put up
the jet schedule because I think it gets
interesting they can and Sam Donald a
couple of weeks ago talking about
possibly being alive for the postseason
and people scoffed and now they've won
three in a row and one in seven became
four and seven they've got at the
bengals five and seven dolphins six and
seven at the Ravens pay no attention
that man behind the curtain
Steelers bills look they can win four
out of the last five and get to eight
and eight that's probably not gonna be
good enough the key is gonna be week 15
eight maybe but kids are Baltimore and
stun the rain oh I don't think they can
I don't see that that would be something
but I think everybody else they're on
that the schedule that you mentioned I
go that's not crazy to think the Jets
can't pull that game off I mean
certainly the Bengals the Dolphins but
they could they could give the bills a
tough time the bills aren't gonna blow
anybody yeah I mean you could take the
defense off the field sometimes and that
game still gonna be close all I know is
I'm starting to feel at least partially
vindicated for having preseason faith in
the Jets I wish I would have looked more
closely at their early season schedule
because you were right they had a tough
road but now they're at a spot where
they can rack up when it dictates season
sometimes you know if the Raiders
started out with that schedule to start
the year I don't think they're sitting
here you know it what are they six and
five now it's just sometimes you get a
little unlucky there and yes the Jets
had the hardest started the season on
any team in football all right from me a
superlative the best revenge is living
well award that goes to Jarvis Landry
who had 10 catches for a hundred and
forty eight yards and two touchdowns
against the team that traded him to the
Cleveland Browns in 2018 and Landry
quietly is having a spectacular season
you know he told me a couple of weeks
ago he's noticed that teams are putting
their best corner on odo Beckham jr.
yeah and letting that guy travel with
Beckham meanwhile Landry's leading the
team and
he's leading the team in yards so much
for Odell Beckham jr. Landry still the
machine right and he's still getting it
done and he had a great great day
against a team that he surely still
harbors some ill will toward court and
the Browns here they are they've won
three in a row yeah another one of these
examples where the schedule sorry's
telling you do I right and from three
and six to two to six wait they were
three and six what are they five and
five and six still if they've won three
in a row they've gone from two and six
to five and six with three straight wins
and they're very much a lot and our Tony
Dungy thinks whoever wins Steelers
Browns this week could be the he thinks
they're gonna be one of the teams that
are at the six seed when all said and
done there really is a cluster of teams
yes that are jockeying for that last
spot and I'll tell you what we were
talking about this last night if I'm one
of the teams that is high up on the on
this the list of seating I don't want
the Colts roll into town I don't want
the Steelers I don't want the cult yeah
the Browns I think I could live with
yeah who knows the way they're playing
now you don't wonder
they're dangerous you know again I'll
make the point of this they outplayed
the Seattle Seahawks and screwed the
game up I think if we mark down the
plays against the New England Patriots
they one more plays in that game than
the New England Patriots did but what
they do they turned it over on three
straight plays you know so they lost
that game they are they beat the Buffalo
Bills a few weeks ago you could say what
you want the bills are the bills are
eight in three they beat them the
Pittsburgh Steelers they dominated them
on Thursday night a few weeks ago so
there is talent there and I would say
watch out this'll be a big game I mean
and I was gonna use this is one of my
superlatives too so I'm glad you did
because yeah I mean it finally Odell and
Jarvis get a touchdown pass in the same
game right that's the first time all
year that's happened
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports